there's a partner in our book everything
that remains is a actual scene that I
was driving I 71 the Cincinnati and it's
bumper-to-bumper traffic some of the
worst traffic in the countries in
Cincinnati and as I'm going south I'm
stopped we're going zero miles now I
look to my right and the person in the
driver's seat has a newspaper over the
wheel and a bowl of cereal in their hand
like the worst kind of multitasking here
and just milk is dripping down their
chin and as they're reading the paper
and and we looked at that like oh that's
that's not right yeah but now we look at
and say oh yeah I do that too yeah so so
they normalized it so that's a problem
right lack of solitude the other problem
is taking this sort of social processing
hardware that again is incredibly
specialized it's the the story of our
species success is that we have these
social supercomputers that can do this
like I can I can talk with you guys I
can look at your facial expressions I
can practice limbic consonants where I
try to match the pacing I'm doing
something called mentalizing right now
where I'm building a model of your mind
in my mind so that I can test against
this model how you would react the
different things I mean right it's a
social super inator but it's evolved for
I'm with people you know people have
known for a long time
we're in person or interacting this just
messes with it it doesn't know how to
deal with like a comment you know like a
bad tweet or something like that right
I'm gonna be treated as if the person's
right across because our brain doesn't
know the difference right so it's like
oh my god like someone in my tribe is
really mad at me like I got to get a
spear in the back like Red Alert right
but it's some Rando on Twitter or the
likes coming in that I get more likes or
not likes our brain is seeing this is
like we're around the campfire and I can
see that you know the the tribe mates
are unhappy with me like this is this is
a serious issue right I need to manage
the social dynamic so this brain does
not know at all how to deal with this
sort of artificial sociality that was
sort of again schemed up in a dorm room
at Harvard you know fifteen years ago or
it's not some grand experiment so that's
also in the final thing is we're losing
the ability to concentrate and this is
one of the issues I mean totally
this has economic consequence ik whence
is the quality of life for sure if you
can't just be present in a moment you
can't concentrate on something that
you're seeing if you can't concentrate a
conversation it's having economic
consequences I mean non industrial
productivity metrics have been stagnant
throughout this last ten years of all
this technological innovation we have a
whole generation of people entering the
workforce that are incredibly
uncomfortable with sustaining attention
at the same time that our economy is
shifting more and more towards the thing
we do is have brains concentrate and
produce value we're going towards this
high-level knowledge economy where this
is like the most important resource we
have this is our oil fields right and
we're getting worse and worse at using
it so I he's right I mean Sachs is right
about this is that what's happening to
our brain is is really non-trivial and
you're at t v-- did this too but you
only but you watch TV in the evening
you